the Saudi journalist Jamal Kakashi as he
arrives at the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul minutes later the Washington
Post columnist would be murdered inside
the building by Saudi agents now were
you an expert says his enemies at the
very top of the government are to blame
execution of mr. Cassidy was the
responsibility of the state of Saudi
Arabia
shortly after cachaca she entered the
embassy these two men left one of them
was dressed to look like the journalist
complete with a fake beard this picture
shows the two suspects in the background
apparently disposing of evidence members
of the hit squad then left the country
on this private plane but despite the
cover-up the UN believes it knows who
the brains behind the operation were
what I do have is evidence suggesting
that the responsibilities of high-level
officials may be engaged and therefore
is requiring further investigation in
particular of the conference Mohammed
bin Salman is literally the power behind
the throne in the desert kingdom
Jamarcus shocked she was a vehement
critic of NBS as he's known the report
cites unverified leaked conversations in
which bin Salman is accused of saying
he'd like to use a bullet on cachaça she
weeks after the journalists death Saudi
prosecutors charge 11 men with his
killing but the UN report finds that
others are still free it's expert says
sanctions should be implemented against
those who are behind this crime
including possibly the crown prince it
is a logical step for me to
be asking for him to be included in the
sanctions until and unless there is
evidence provided that he was not
involved
Jamarcus shocked she was 59 years old he
survived by his fiancee and four
children
his widow her teachers Angus has
welcomed the report and she's joined
calls for the world's top House to take
responsibility and ensure that justice
is done
Agnes calamar joins us now she's the UN
Special Rapporteur on extrajudicial
executions who issued that report thanks
so much for joining us today how did you
reach the conclusion that there is quote
credible evidence that Saudi authorities
were involved in casualties death so the
first important finding of my inquiry is
about the responsibilities of the state
of Saudi Arabia until now the Saudi
authorities have insisted that this was
not a state sanction crime but a rogue
operations what my report shows is that
the killing of mr. Khashoggi meets all
of the criteria for a state crime it was
conducted and done by state officials it
used it relied upon state means and
state resources the team that came into
Istanbul used private jet with
diplomatic clearance the killing took
place in the Saudi consulate the Saudi
console himself took actions so that
there were no witnesses on the day and
at the time of the killing these and
other evidence presented in the report
mean that there is no other conclusions
but that the killing was what we call a
state killing if it was a state killing
done by state officials as your report
found with state resources does that
mean that the crown prince bin Solomon
is responsible or
for the killing of keshavjee so my
investigation is a human rights
investigation focusing heavily on the
responsibilities of the state in that
context I have considered individual
liability only to identify whether or
not there was in my opinion sufficient
credible evidence mandating an
international criminal investigation my
conclusion is that on the basis of what
I have found and analyzed there is
indeed credible evidence demanding a
criminal investigation into high-level
officials including the Crown Prince
what I also want to insist upon is that
the possible liability of the Crown
Prince is not only derived from whether
or not he ordered the crime
the search for smoking gun is important
but it is not the only form of
responsibilities for a high-level
official within a civilian setting there
is something close to a chain of command
and a range of responsibilities
associated with it for instance did the
Crown Prince or someone else
directly or indirectly incite the
killing of mr. Khashoggi did the
conference of someone else knew about
the proposed killing but failed to take
action to prevent it did the Crown
Prince or someone else knew or should
have known that the killing of mr.
khashoggi was a possibility in light of
the multiple violations of human right
that had taken place in the year
preceding is killing all of those issues
must be the object of an in-depth
criminal investigation okay where should
this criminal investigation take place
what should the jurisdiction bait
so my my recommendation is that the
international criminal investigation be
conducted at the level of the United
Nation I call upon the Secretary General
to appoint a panel of expert that will
look into individual liabilities on the
basis of the the evidence
agnus calamari special un repertoire on
extrajudicial executions thank you so
very much for your time today with DW
news